[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and this is the
channel where we explain it so you don't
have to after it was confirmed today
that the new Joker film will be the
first r-rated DC movie we also have
several brand new leaks on the story
that have come forth these new details
alter several of the recently reported
on plot points and throughout this video
I'll be breaking down everything you
need to know about the movie and its
storyline this is full spoilers ahead
and whilst we won't know whether these
details are correct until we see the
movie for ourselves there are
potentially a lot of things here that
could ruin the film so I highly suggest
that you turn off now if you don't want
anything spoiled we saw with my Avengers
end game and Game of Thrones finale
videos that these plot leaks are often
pretty accurate so this is your last
last last chance to turn back without
the way I just want to give a huge thank
you for clicking this video I hope you
enjoy it
now sit back relax and let's get into my
breakdown of joke okay so the first
thing you need to know is that the movie
is set in 1981 Gotham which is when the
city is at its lowest point due to a
seemingly unending crime wave in
addition to this there's a garbage
strike which means that Gotham is pretty
dirty both literally and figuratively
the film follows the rise of Arthur
Fleck who is initially just a clown for
a talent agency black has severe mental
health issues that include laughing when
he's nervous and because of this a
social worker keeps a close eye on him
black wishes to become a stand-up comic
but due to his nerves his sets are often
ruined and thus he never really gets
anywhere black is also a caretaker for
his mother who just so happens to be a
former housekeeper of Wayne mansion
which I'll get into later the household
headed up by Thomas Wayne is currently
in the spotlight because Wayne is
running for mayor those who read Batman
as one will remember that in that Thomas
was running for mayor against the
penguin and that the character was
killed for it so that the miniature
crime boss could become elected and
control the city whilst there's no
mention of penguin in the script we have
heard leaks that the villain will be
appearing in the Matt Reeves Batman
movie starring Robert Pattinson and
whilst the two films are not meant
be connected it would be amazing if
penguin was the mayor in that movie
having being elected here first
anyway flex mother is obsessed with the
mayoral candidate and apparently Wayne
fired her from working at the property
because of this black desperate for
money takes a new job but after he's
mocked on the subway he cracked slightly
and violently kills three wall street
guys who were also harassing a young
woman and these murders inspire a resist
movement against Gotham's wealthiest
basically this film will center around
the poor uprising against the rich
similar to The Dark Knight Rises and due
to this Thomas Wayne who is viewed as
the boss of the wealthy becomes a target
it's at this point that Arthur tries his
hand at stand-up comedy but once more he
completely bombs so badly that footage
of his performance is picked up by
Murray Franklin a TV show host played by
Robert DeNiro Franklin completely
ridicules the character making him a
national joke now in the recent plot
leak it was stated that police are
investigating Arthur for the murders
committed earlier in the film which is
when he apparently stumbles across a
pretty major revelation and his mother's
letters to Thomas Wayne she claims that
they had an affair and that Arthur is
the illegitimate son of Thomas thus
making Bruce Wayne and the Joker related
however the new details from the fraud
leak have stated that this is in fact a
lie orchestrated by Arthur's crazy
mother as a last-ditch attempt to get
Thomas to pay attention to her Arthur
will throughout some of the movie
believe that he is in fact Bruce's
brother however when he discovers the
truth he will go completely off the deep
end repressed memories of Arthur's
childhood re-emerge and he remembers
that when he was little he was abused by
his mother's boyfriend who actually
turns out to be his real father
at this point Arthur goes to Arkham
Asylum and tells us
he's also invited on the Murray Franklin
show as a guest Joker appears on the
show shooting Franklin in the head and
delivering a speech to rile up Gotham
City this is of course pretty similar to
the scene from the Dark Knight Returns
and which Joker kills a chat show host
before going on a rampage and in the
film he goes out and murders people
who've wronged him throughout the movie
now we have heard rumors that the film
ends with Thomas and Martha Wayne being
gunned down in an alley however these
new plot leaks suggests Ed's after the
speech that this happens this is because
Joker sends the city into a riot due to
his words and the attackers purposely go
to Wayne mansion to kill the characters
in their beds
Bruce scared of what's going on runs out
of the mansion and off into the night
which is when he falls into the cave
thus saying of what will happen in the
future with the character he's found by
Alfred and a couple of days later he
heads to their memorial which is when he
encounters Joker joke had been on the
run for several days but with the police
looking over Wayne they notice him and
begin to chase him the police run after
Arthur through Gotham but they finally
managed to catch him after he's hit by a
taxi and the film ends with the
character in Arkham Asylum dancing
around his cell maniacally to Elton
John's Bennie and the Jets which ends
the movie and goes off into the credits
so this all sounds pretty interesting
and I'm kind of glad that the whole
Joker / Bruce Wayne brother thing has
been dropped and it was something I feel
like shouldn't have been in the movie at
all I'm someone who pretty much thinks
that the Joker's origin should always
remain a mystery as he's pretty much
just a force of nature however if we do
have to get an origin story then yet
this sounds pretty good it's also very
alien to Marvel as well which I think DC
have wrongly been trying to copy for the
past couple of years to no avail so I'm
definitely more hyped for seeing the
movie after reading this and I think
that it has the potential to be pretty
big and if the rumors are true then we
are no doubt in for a fantastic
performance from Joaquin Phoenix
obviously I'd love to hear your thoughts
on the film and if you believe these pot
leaks or not comment below and let me
know and if you enjoyed this video then
please like it and make sure you check
out my breakdown of the MCU phase 4
which would be linked at the end it
contains everything we know so far about
the upcoming
films and it's definitely worth watching
if you want to know more so I'll link
that at the end this is a channel for
people who are super into superheroes so
if that's the kind of thing you like hit
subscribe thanks again for taking the
time to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best and I'll see you next time take
care peace
[Music]
[Music]